action a spiritual intuition that that's
really what I do it sounds much better
doesn't tie you up with all this madame
lasagna so I Kim says yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm having coffee with an Armstrong an
old friend of mine from Esalen days and
his beloved psychic and has a pretty
impeccable reputation as a seer which is
a difficult very line of work yes how
are you enjoying Prague I'm enjoying it
very much it's one of the most beautiful
cities I have ever seen very impressed
and needless to say the vibes are very
intense you know if you tune into it
psychically and get the first full
impact of what's here it's it's a
tremendous feeling I've had similar
experiences in in Europe in in Rome but
when I went through the Jewish cemetery
that was that was quite a thing for me
it sounds like you can just feel all the
pain and sorrow and deep privation that
those poor people in - yes in Prague
gets really a paradox you know it was
said that under communism it was of a
gloomy City - yeah and yet it seems
pretty vibrant do you have a notion of
how this situation is moving here
what sort of a future do you envision
for the chick well I feel especially
Prague is like like an open door a
gateway that I feel is allowing people
to finally express you know their deep
feelings how they felt without feeling
you know being censored in any way so I
have you know it's just like all of a
sudden a whole other part of their life
is coming into into perspective and
certainly I feel the sense of
spirituality here to everyone that you
talk to everybody's interested you can't
communicate fluently but you certainly
feel from them that they're hungry for
this and that is certainly certainly you
know a rare opportunity for them well
when you look into the past of
Czechoslovakia certainly it's been a
long hard road to hoe right can you look
toward the future and see any difference
or is it the same story again I think
there will remain an underlying sameness
because we're used to certain you know
certain ways of being but I also feel
that the more like like the more
adventuresome individuals and more
knowing you know like the sense of deep
knowing individuals will begin to see
everything very differently and I look
for them to become the leaders for the
rest of the people like just say you
experienced it this way but I'm
experiencing it this way and let's go
from there so I do feel you know feel
very hopeful and I'm aware of how
beautiful these people are I just get
get weepy when I don't look at that
they're just radiant beautiful people
that have been oppressed and are now
finally having an opportunity to be
liberated and it's you know slow change
comes very slowly but I feel that it
will happen it is going to happen for
them and it's time and they do
they've worked for it it's like their
bad karma may be over with it feels like
it yeah at least for the Bohemian party
that's wrong that's right I'm loathe to
ask this but perverse curiosity
overcomes me what about our own sad
union well this is one of the things
that any time I go into a deep space I
take a look at and even though we see
like hopeful rays of light you know in
our in our part of the world I'm also
seeing the other side
and since on occasion I'm able to tune
into a much deeper level like a more
esoteric level of a scene I'm aware that
we have a certain timeframe and no time
is kind of running out so that unless
there is a big big switch you know to
owning our power in our spirituality and
our light that we're on the brink of
disaster
and this really concerns me a lot I know
just the earthquake activity in
California has been something and I look
for more so you're not talking about
political or economic disaster no you're
talking about something more an act of
God all that's right because it seems
that what brings people together is when
we have disasters we have a need you
know to support each other and I would
hate to see it come to that you know to
that place where we actually have a
tremendous disaster illness or for
instance like AIDS becomes even more
prevalent where we will have to band
together
well you know some people feel that the
undoing of the Soviet Union can really
be traced to the Chernobyl okay I think
it can everything has a you know has a a
result well now didn't someone here at
this conference this seems to me like a
recurring theme it's the idea that
things are going to get worse before
they get better because there needs to
be some kind of shock awakening that's
what I feel is is somehow you know as
long as we're comfortable we're very
complacent but when all of a sudden our
life is threatened and just our general
environment is threatened then we you
know we rise up in arms we get you know
we become very activated and I'm just
hoping that somehow we won't have to
come to that to that point before we
will all see you know we will all see
the same picture together and do
something about it
and I I'm always asking myself you know
what what can you do about it and so Jim
and I of course spread the word under
the guise of teaching people to be
intuitive we slip a lot of the spiritual
teaching into it in the sense of
individual responsibility but ultimately
I think that what what needs to happen I
think one of the speaker's mentioned
this was that somehow we do have that
that essence within us the power within
us that I feel is equivalent to the atom
bomb I feel that the atom bomb was
simply an externalization
of you know what we have inside of us
and that what we have inside of us is
greater and that if we can have
awareness of that part of the self and
use it project it out there create more
light perhaps we will invite some
friendlier forces so really it seems
like what you're saying is into it
is simply an opening to what is already
there what is already there and this is
the reason that you know we do stress
our intuition workshops is because it's
like it gives you a lens to look through
it's a way of getting into a deeper
larger part of yourself but you can also
use it you know for exploring other
dimensions of consciousness personally I
just read about it but personally and
this is what is fascinating do you think
is it I mean it's clear we're all
motivated to try and do something to try
and make the world better but what I
worry about is is there enough urgency I
don't think there is yet so
unfortunately I don't think there is
we're still half asleep yes and I feel
that one of these days Mother Nature may
get very impatient shake her back and
we'll get it and perhaps we need it I
mean perhaps we have to be you know done
that too you know we have to be done too
before we wake up and say okay what's
important in my life because I feel so
many people have lost sense of personal
responsibility having fun all the outer
things or what it you know are so so
important rather than the true meaning
for their life and that is their life
script and to find out who they are and
how they can get there and how they can
contribute so people have been
distracted by the surface
and that that really concerns me but I
said I don't know what what more we can
do about it
except do what you can on an individual
basis but we are in a crisis well with
the collapse of communism now there are
no competing value systems other than
the work works and spins funfun funfun I
managed to things I mean whatever one
thinks of communism a lot of traditional
culture was preserved in a kind of
economic deep freeze I mean I'm sure
Czechoslovakia is headed toward more
comfort more consumer electronics but
are they headed toward happiness well
that's what I've been looking at all of
these new things these new choices that
they have and all of a sudden you free
and you can buy and you can you can
imitate the United States and that's a
concern because some of the values that
I find here are very deep in ancient and
I feel have a tremendous amount of
create stability in a society and they
may be taken away and that is a consoled
out know that for something something
different run yes well in a way these
people are no different from rainforest
Indians sort of ethics or whatever of
cultural worth they have we will package
and export and everything else it's be
devalued that's what happens
I would I would like to say a little bit
about intuition please because I feel
that most people you know you you read
about it or you're here the people you
know hint at it and you know that you
have this ability inside of you like you
have the perfect plan inside of you and
yet there isn't you know an easy way to
get to it except through arduous years
and years and years of meditation so
what we try to do is to do it in a more
playful way to literally trick people
into finding out that hey they can
really see they can really know without
ever having the other person say
anything and I feel like it's a way of
getting people into that space so that
later on there will be curiosity there
will be a lot of curiosity and the
curiosity may lead them to a deeper
search you know of themselves and that's
that's our gig so really what your what
your couching as intuition is
self-awareness exactly self gross
self-awareness appreciation of that part
of yourself but it's much easier to rope
people in if you sell it as a pound or
it's more glamorous yeah and but you
know the thing is to get the audience
and then and then talk to them to get
them to take get them to take and to
realize it's somehow you know it's in
there it's in there and I feel like the
way we do it we do it in a kind of
playful way but also we do
and they say glamorize it we don't say
there's certain steps that have to be
taken but we most of the time the bottom
line we say do it and they don't
challenge they don't question and they
do it and this has been very very
gratifying for me because out of that
has come a lot of people in the world
now that came to that part of themselves
that their their tasks that they gave
themselves if there's such a thing and
there are doing it because they found
out that they had this thing inside of
his quality of restlessness and all of a
sudden there's a forum point so it
sounds like a lot of what you do is give
permission permission to be alright what
is all there yeah and in the private
work that I do what I usually go for
what are the blocks that are keeping
that person from real you know realizing
their their greater potential and so in
a sense it's a combination of
psychological work as well as
spirituality and the self responsibility
well and I think you provide an example
I try well you do a good job well I
think I think I provided an example in
that for the first about 25 or 30 years
of my life I was very ill and I didn't
know what the nature of my illness was
nobody Mayo Clinic and you know fine
doctors could not find out and actually
what was happening to me is that I was
suppressing my intuitive ability my
psychic ability to fit him yeah well I
didn't know I had it there was I started
this business a long time ago so I was
kind of a closeted psychic but as a
child I had these feelings and this
knowings but there was nowhere no gurus
around no no no way to check it out
and until you know the law of
synchronicity began to operate in my
life and I found the right therapist and
I did some regression work and find out
found out some of the past lives that
apparently were still reaching into the
present and affecting me
and the outcome was that I healed myself
of everything that I had wrong with me
so that's one of the things that I try
to push like what so you know what is
your illness teaching you what is it
trying to tell you how can you get past
it and once you get past it once you get
rid of the the blocks then the real
stuff that you're here to do or inspired
to do will come out and that's exactly
what happened to me before that it was I
felt powerless so because you had this
as a direct experience Gary great
conviction to speak to other people
that's right that it's possible not all
illnesses you know are connected with
with a spiritual and spiritual emergency
but a lot of them are it's the way that
our soul somehow gets our attention
through pain through distorting the
physical right until yes until we ask
enough questions and say what's going on
if we're ready to hear it's there it's
all there well maybe we could make a
hopeful metaphor and expand that to the
global level yes that's what I hope for
and say you know the earth is trying to
get our attention I mean surely all of
your nature it's trying because trying I
was I have you know in my intuitive
state tuned in to mother nature because
you can tune into any any you know any
form any system and what of what she has
said to me is that I'm saying I'm very
very sad
it's almost like you know I'm being
destroyed being consumed in
very negative ways and that's not my
function my function is to provide a
wonderful living space for us to grow in
so generally are you hopeful about human
fate Geordi I am I have a lot of faith
in individuals I really do because I
feel that once we wake up like you know
we're movers and we do things so I think
the trick is how do you wake more people
up all at once so the real situation is
that the real struggle to save the
planet has not yet begun I don't think
so
we're still doing we're still drifting
we still haven't gotten that at the
point that we are in a tremendous crisis
and once we get everybody awakened to
that and focused this is exactly what I
think that it's going to take some
terrible terrible hundred thousand
people could die it's no no doubt about
it
and that is a constant concern of mine
but I'm very gratified about all these
what is the the thing that happened the
New Year's Day or what was a the where
all the people band together and prayed
at the same time all of that I feel is
like wonderful light energy that is
being set up in other words because I
feel that the higher forces cannot reach
down to us I can only come down to a
certain level so we have to elevate
ourselves to meet them have some kind of
a meeting ground and if we can get there
the whole thing can be shifted in in a
matter of hours or minutes you know HG
Wells said history is a race between
education and catastrophe and it looks
to me like it's gonna be a photo in I
think it will be
but I still have faith that somehow you
know we're heartful enough and loving
enough and caring enough to see the to
see the real picture that there must be
a purpose in in the human adventure it
isn't just it isn't just an adventure no
it is but the goal is enlightenment you
see and I'm not I'm not sure that we've
gotten that message that clearly it that
clearly defined well it's hard to tell
whether we're collectively moving
towards some kind of global
enlightenment or we're simply moving
toward the ruination of everything well
the whole thing is attitude it depends
upon how we feel what we do what we
think in the next few years as to what
the outcome will be where you say
attitude I would say it's language
language you can't live a future you
can't describe that's right so we have
to really the heart and the imagination
the mind has to have a target that it
understands and I see if I think as yet
we have not gotten that target every you
know little pockets of people here and
there of course have it but no general
fusion
that's right well thank you very much
you're very welcome I'm glad I I'm glad
I did this yes good well wait I can't be
it so I've been telling hopefully change
a few minds
I chose even one line well I've managed
to do a lot of that
[Music]
[Music]
it's very much knocking oh yeah I'm
always running off with fix the plumbing
can I still can have that that's right
oh that's yours
that's this is a high-budget operation
you're here looking after your profit
Andrew it tasted that it's the best
without ads insights are here